well um Jennifer is also a founding
investor of the Angel City Football Club
the women's soccer team in Los Angeles
which is so cool but I think that's
awesome we're going to get to that but
here she is at another soccer match here
you
go you're the one yelling you're the one
yelling I'm like I suddenly know what's
happening just cuz I'm an investor in
Angel City it's like I go to Angel City
I'm clueless I know I'm clueless I just
am smiling having a good time bits and
pieces you know I mean Abby wach and and
Glenn doer they tell me things I love
them by the way they cool I know so I'm
learning I'm there a lot but as soon as
I'm out and I'm like my nephew's game in
West Virginia I'm suddenly an expert
yelling things you know hey ref that's a
yellow card I don't know what
I love that people at the game are like
is that no like really I grew up with
everyone at the game that's my my sister
my yeah that's my town oh that's awesome
they've all known me they are not
impressed family is like a movie that's
awesome they are not impressed I'm
[Music]
[Applause]
there
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home